this is supposedly hostile territory for
emmanuel macron in the first round of
france's presidential election 49
percent of the vote in sandini went to
the far-left candidate jean-luc
melenchon
in the second round the choice is macron
or the far right's marine le pen
we feel like we have to choose between
the pest and cholera this woman told the
president
the high cost of living is the main
concern for french voters and jobs this
woman says
nationwide unemployment has fallen under
macron to 7.9 percent but it's high here
at 11
we're creating jobs macron says before
adding there's no magic solution
there are millions of potential
melanchome king makers the far left
candidate hasn't himself endorsed macron
though he's told his supporters there
should not be a single vote for marine
le pen macron also wants to tap the
youth vote 31 percent of 18 to 24 year
olds voted for jean-luc melenchon
to the north of paris saint sandini is
one of the most deprived areas of france
here macron struggles to shake off his
image as president of the rich but the
far right is even more unpopular
there's no other choice i don't see
myself voting for marie le pen because
she doesn't reflect my principles so i'd
rather be shot by macron than marine
i will vote for macron this time i don't
like what he does but i'll be voting for
macron as a vote against le pen
i think macron has already done one term
and i think to allow continuity will be
more advantageous the latest polls
suggest emanuel macron will win a second
term but he will only keep the
presidency with votes cast grudgingly in
his favor
bernard smith al jazeera saints
underneath